[Music]
on this thursday night a long delayed
commitment to justice for missing and
murdered indigenous women and girls
what's absent from the plan the prime
minister calls transformative
i was a little disappointed plus the
class action lawsuit for reparations for
the impact of residential schools why
the federal government
is fighting it they put their lives on
the line to help soldiers in afghanistan
the taliban ghana finally and they
killed me
the dangers interpreters now face after
u.s
troops leave return of the hug the new
rules ontario's long-term care residents
will soon embrace
and to boldly go where we haven't gone
in decades
what nasa hopes to learn by venturing
back to venus
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a number of threads about
the treatment of indigenous people
in this country the prime minister is
promising transformative change two
years after a report on missing and
murdered indigenous women and girls was
released
in ottawa another tribute to the
children found in unmarked graves in
kamloops
whether it is residential schools or
missing women and girls indigenous
people
have said for years the country's
justice system is riddled with racism
we'll have more in a moment on the
action plan unveiled today but we begin
with a class action lawsuit the federal
government is fighting right now
more than 100 first nations are seeking
reparations
for the impact of residential schools
the lawsuit alleges indigenous
communities have lost in whole or in
part their traditional economic
viability
self-government and laws language land
base and land-based teachings
the government in court filings denies
any responsibility
our chief political correspondent david
aiken has our top story tonight
david well donna in 2007
a settlement was reached that saw most
survivors of residential schools
qualify for payments out of a three
billion dollar compensation
fund but a few years after that in 2012
two bc first nations including the first
nations in kamloops
said that residential schools did not
harm just individuals
the residential school system harmed
entire communities
and so they sued and were soon joined in
a class action lawsuit
by other first nations now numbering 105
from across the country
their common argument the residential
school system
ultimately affected the entire
community's ability
to perpetuate their culture perpetuate
their language
or to do things like properly defend
land claims and the federal government
ought to pay for that harm
how do you govern a community where
nearly your entire population
has had their children forcibly removed
not
over one generation but over several
generations
and there's the disconnection from their
language and their culture and their
all of this how do you address that i
mean this is this
is horrific in court filings the federal
government acknowledges that
yes residential schools we're harmful
and wrong but
as a matter of law canada did not commit
any
unlawful act that could be said to have
harmed the bans
and in any event the government says the
harm suffered by first nations over a
century or more
was a result of a whole host of other
cultural
social and economic factors the parties
have
differing views on who is legally
responsible
to compensate for any harms caused by or
through
the creation of these schools now some
advocates and some parliamentarians say
that the federal government ought to get
out of court
and sit down and negotiate these claims
as part of the
reconciliation process no word today if
in fact that is the plan for the trudeau
government
but in the meantime these first nations
are preparing to go to trial
likely in the fall of 2022. donna
all right david aiken in ottawa thank
you now to the promises made today about
missing and murdered indigenous women
and girls the prime minister said
voices have been heard and the
government will spend more to support
language culture
infrastructure health and policing but
critics say it includes no specific
timelines and no details on how exactly
the money will be spent
abigail beeman reports will never be
forgotten
two years after an inquiry cited a
genocide for indigenous women and girls
a long list of partners presented a
national action plan
we shine a spotlight on the immediate
actions that need to be taken
we need accountability inclusion
interconnectedness
and concrete actions the short-term
goals are wide-ranging and include a
guaranteed annual livable income
a nationwide emergency number and a
24-hour in-person support system
and a national task force to review and
re-investigate
unresolved files but there's no costing
nor
time frame for any of that then
confusingly
there's ottawa's portion a 30-page
federal pathway
promising more investments in language
culture safety and justice
many commitments are vague none are
costed
the minister in charge refused to be
clear about whether ottawa will
implement those big ticket national
action plan
items i think what we are saying is that
we support them
and now as we move to implementation
we obviously will will
be able to ever green the pathway this
is our big concern and
the confusion around i think this plan
today
people may be under the impression that
these initiatives that are being brought
forth by the
the groups are actually going to be put
in place and funded it falls short
from what i expected the document is a
disappointment for john fox senior his
daughter cheyenne fell to her death from
a 24th story balcony in toronto in 2013.
he believes she was murdered that's
what's been happening with this with
these issues
with the missing and murdered women
girls
and they're just kind of being left on
the back burner indigenous women and
girls and 2s people
are dying and the work has to be done
promptly
so uh personally yes i am disappointed
that it's taken this long
other stakeholders say they were left
out of the whole process while the
native women's association of canada
walked away from it earlier this week
citing concerns with the federal
government's
lack of concrete action now it says it
will launch a human rights complaint and
call on the united nations
to investigate abigail beeman global
news
ottawa murray sinclair the former chair
of the truth and reconciliation
commission is calling for an independent
investigation
into unmarked and lost grave sites at
residential schools
he told a house of commons committee
today nothing has been done on the
matter since the commission released its
final report six years ago
that is he said a sad commentary on the
lack of commitment the government has to
try to
close the story of what happened at
residential schools
we need to ensure that there is an
independent
study that is done into that question of
those
burial sites and that investigation
should not be conducted under the
auspices of the federal government but
should be overseen
by a parliamentary committee
that will ensure that it is done in a
proper way
the last residential school closed in
the late 1990s
the trauma though has not ended the
ripple effects have been pervasive
across
generations nithu garcia is looking into
that tonight
but it hit hard a week after it was
announced the kamloops residential
school discovery packs a painful punch
sorry it's just we're all saying that as
each day goes by it's actually getting
harder
so sorry the executive director of
kikikyoka place of belonging says
the child welfare system is failing
indigenous children
and this one-of-a-kind youth and elder
housing facility is a solution
because it promotes healing rather than
perpetuating trauma
that runs generations deep the rates of
homelessness
uh chronic addictions mental health
incarceration death is
it's alarming it's it's unex it's just
unacceptable
she says the government-owned 31 unit
center which opened less than a year ago
doesn't have an age out of care
philosophy
and ensures those living here are
represented and remember their cultural
lineage
first nations people know what they need
they need to lead and
develop their services the children
grandchildren
are at greater risk for psychological
distress so symptoms of anxiety and
depression compared to
those indigenous families who were not
affected by the residential school
system
researchers at dalhousie university have
found there are biological impacts to a
person's stress response system
from trauma which many of those living
with it want to be trusted with tackling
we have the solutions but the thing is
is we
we didn't create this and it can't just
be
left to us to fix it all and
you know if there's a gift out of this
it's those 215 little children
their lives have created this awakening
nitu garcia global news kamloops bc
now to covet 19 and new attempts by the
government to make people obey
federal quarantine rules starting
tomorrow the fine for air travelers who
refuse to quarantine in a designated
hotel will increase from three thousand
to
five thousand dollars last week a
government advisory panel flagged major
problems with the quarantine hotel
system including
that some travelers choose to pay the
fine rather than obey the rules
the panel calls for the government to
scrap the hotels and instead
allow travelers with a credible plan to
quarantine on their own
some long-awaited freedom is finally
coming to long-term care residents and
their families in ontario
the province says starting next
wednesday wednesday regardless of
vaccination status residents will be
allowed brief hugs with visitors
if both the resident and the visitor are
fully vaccinated there can be closer
physical contact including hand holding
and fully vaccinated residents will be
allowed to leave their homes
for day and overnight trips well getting
more people fully vaccinated is key
manitoba is now offering a million
dollars worth of grants
to try to help community groups like
religious organizations and sports
associations will be eligible for the
grants of up to twenty thousand dollars
to
promote immunization fifty five percent
of all manitobans have had
at least one dose we have to get past
the 70
vaccination mark we have to get to 75
then to 80
then to 85 and higher those numbers are
achievable and necessary
so we can get our freedoms back
overall in canada 59 of people have had
at least one dose and
six percent of the population has been
fully vaccinated
in the u.s more than half the population
is now fully vaccinated and
covid 19 case counts are down 94
from their peak it is now back to where
things were in march of 2020.
that has prompted the biden
administration to look outside its
borders
it's going to share millions of vaccine
doses with the world
as jackson proskow reports canada is set
to receive some of the u.s supply
even as pressure amounts on ottawa to
share excess vaccine doses we have
ordered
with developing nations having come
so far the u.s is ready to share its
vaccine success with the world
our overarching aim is to get as many
safe and effective vaccines
to as many people as fast as possible
by the end of june the biden
administration will donate 80 million
doses of vaccine to other countries
of the first 25 million doses 75 percent
will go to kovacs
the global vaccine sharing program for
developing nations
the other 25 percent 6 million doses
will go directly to u s allies and
partners including canada
mexico the west bank and gaza and india
in many countries the worst days of the
pandemic are just arriving
some developing nations still have not
started vaccinating at all
and so canada's inclusion on the us
donation list is raising eyebrows
canada has secured more doses per person
than any other
than any other country the world is
watching us there's growing pressure on
ottawa to give instead of take
canada and the uk are the only g7
nations not to promise doses directly to
kovacs
canada instead purchased nearly 1
million doses from
kovacs and received a loan of 1.5
million doses of astrazeneca vaccine
from the u.s we're calling on the
government to announce
that for every 10 doses given to
canadians
one dose is shared back with the
developing world
to date less than half a percent of all
vaccine doses worldwide have gone to
developing nations
a practice epidemiologists warn is
scientifically
unsound if we want to be able to
preserve the effectiveness of the
vaccines that we have currently now
we want to reduce the amount of time
that this virus is circulating globally
key to the u.s dose donation strategy is
that the vaccines are being given away
without
any conditions on the countries
receiving them that's a model the biden
administration is likely to push
during next week's g7 summit donna
all right jackson prosko thanks that
sinking feeling coming up the massive
sinkhole that
keeps expanding
it is already huge about 60 meters wide
and 15 meters deep and this sinkhole in
southeastern mexico keeps
growing it appeared on saturday owners
of a nearby house say
they heard what sounded like thunder now
their home is on the verge of being
swallowed up
a growing controversy about air canada
is not disappearing it's emerged the
airline
paid about 10 million dollars in bonuses
to its executives while
negotiating a federal bailout all those
opposed to the motion will please say
nay
carried and today in the house of
commons
there was a vote a unanimous one to
condemn air canada's senior management
the prime minister calls the decision to
pay bonuses unacceptable and has asked
for an explanation
new brunswick is creating a committee to
try to diagnose a mysterious
neurological syndrome in that province
doctors
formally identified a cluster of
patients with an unusual combination of
neurological symptoms
in early 2020 at least 48 people ranging
in age from 18 to 86 have the disease
and six have died the committee will
review case files and interview patients
in an effort to identify
what is making people sick fearing for
their lives
interpreters in afghanistan who help
canadian soldiers
now need our help
in 100 days american troops pull out of
afghanistan and left behind will be
hundreds of interpreters who work
closely
with soldiers including canadian
soldiers they would have been lost
without the interpreters
both the uk and the us have expanded
their plans to get those people and
their families out of the country
as mike armstrong explains they fear the
taliban is coming for them
they were there in afghanistan just
about any time canadian troops went
anywhere sometimes interpreters wore
slightly different uniforms
sometimes they wore candidates my
interpreter was
was my lifeline dave morrow served in
afghanistan as a military liaison
between civilians and soldiers
a job he says would have been impossible
without interpreters and their knowledge
of pashtu
andari two of the local languages their
men moro says he trusted with his life
that as soon as the u.s leaves the
taliban intends to kill
the country is falling quickly and
it's only a matter of time before
everybody that worked for us is is going
to be
a target of their of their attacks what
are you hoping
the federal government does well i'm
hoping they do the right thing
morrow is part of a group calling on
ottawa to bring interpreters to canada
basically before it's too late with the
u.s pulling out an already desperate
situation is about to get worse
the report since 2016 about 300
interpreters who worked with nato forces
have been killed in recent weeks
interpreters have held
rallies calling for help they say
they're already getting threats from the
taliban and have to live
on the run because if i stay in a place
for like one month
two months three months the taliban
gonna find me
and they killed me now canada did have a
program to relocate interpreters and
their families about 300 people were
brought over but that program expired in
2011.
we know we have a special obligation to
these individuals with the us pulling
out washington is looking at expanding
its program while the uk created a new
one in april
and announced last weekend it's speeding
it up we think it's the right thing to
do to stand by these people
they they sacrificed a lot to look after
us and now we're going to do the same
in my opinion they've served with the
canadian armed forces
moro is still in contact with his
interpreter in afghanistan
it's someone he always promised would
someday move to canada
and someone this country he says has a
moral
obligation to help mike armstrong global
news
montreal
a planet too mysterious for just one
mission next
nasa's big plans for venus
[Music]
well the concord is history but there's
another plan for a plane able to fly
from new york to london in
three and a half hours united airlines
has ordered 15 supersonic jets from a
startup company called
boom supersonic they say it will fly at
twice the speed of today's fastest
airliners and they'll run on 100
biofuel it is still just a plan they
haven't been built
and they still require government
approval it's hoped they'll carry
passengers in
2029.
and this is venus we're going back there
for the first time in 30 years two nasa
spacecraft will venture to the second
planet from the sun
the goal is to investigate the mysteries
of venus including
whether it was actually the first
habitable planet before earth
eric sorensen takes our deep space dive
tonight
it is shrouded and mysterious venus is
similar to earth and passes closer to
our planet than mars ever does
yet it's the neighbor we mostly avoid a
soviet probe 50 years ago took rare
pictures from the surface
the probe was crushed by the atmosphere
within two hours
but now nasa is going back to have a
closer look for the first time in 30
years
with two missions da vinci to measure
the planet's toxic atmosphere
veritas to map the planet's surface we
hope these missions will further
our understanding of how earth evolved
and why
it's currently habitable when others in
our solar
system are not venus might once have had
oceans
then turned into a seemingly
uninhabitable environment
venus may well have been very habitable
comparably placed to the earth and then
things began to change
so how venus got to its current state
is really very important to our
understanding of
planetary evolution venus and mars are
our closest neighbors
temperatures and the potential for life
depend in part on orbiting distance from
the sun
venus is closer and hotter mars further
away and colder
but it's not just location its
atmosphere mars
smaller with a weaker magnetic field
lost most of its atmosphere
earth has a more hospitable atmospheric
blanket that makes life possible here
while venus is enveloped by dense gases
90 times heavier than earth's
a super greenhouse effect that makes
venus so hot
it explains the interest in mars where
probes and landers can exist for years
on venus they would melt but there is so
much to learn from venus that's possible
now
it's exciting for all of us because it's
been
a lot about mars and very little about
other planets
modern instruments will be able to
penetrate the dark mysteries and reveal
even simple facts about venus
does it have volcanoes does it have
valleys what does the surface of venus
really look like recent findings suggest
that that thick atmosphere might harbor
microbial life
other scientists are doubtful these
missions that start in 2028
will answer some of those basic
questions about our neighbor
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
thursday from here on earth i'm donna
friesen tonight's your canada is this
family of geese in riviere
de mille quebec we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching pharah nasser will
be here at the anchor desk tomorrow and
i'll see you
on saturday for the new reality take
care of yourselves
bye-bye
you